peter tell us the story real quick of
the loan that you took to i believe buy
a car and then pay it back so i think
most people here probably haven't heard
that
it wasn't about yeah so what it was i
was just uh
i was laying in bed one morning and it
was during the pool market when the
price crashed to 17 and a half k and i
didn't have any dry powder because um
all my money was in bitcoin so i just
went on my bank website and i was like
how much can i borrow just like that
and they were like 35
000 pounds i was like great that's 2.5
bitcoin cool so i just borrowed it
instantly
um and bought the 2.5 bitcoin i think
yeah that was a big one
uh seventy and a half thousand dollars
so i'm at least like i'm like what a 2x
so two and a half x uh but when the bank
asked me what it was for i was just like
oh it's for a car uh because they didn't
you couldn't put bitcoin they didn't say
that so
so i put for a car and then like a bunch
of idiots on twitter got all upset like
oh you lied to the bank you need to go
to jail you're a criminal yada yada i
was like are you bitcoiners or what's
the [ __ ] anyway i did i did i didn't end
up buying a car so they can jog on but
yeah yeah no i just did a little kind of
like michael sailor move
uh one morning i wish i'd borrowed more
i did try but um they have these checks
in the uk and if you because i did one
the other people would have seen i've
just done one immediately so they kind
of have these panic moments to stop you
keep borrowing loads of money got it and
then when you got up above what you say
58 000 you sold a little bit of bitcoin
and went and bought some super cars
yeah so i bought uh i bought my i bought
myself an aston martin i bought my dad a
jag and i bought a range rover and i
bought myself a mercedes i bought four
cars
what was the decision-making process one
to when you decided to sell a little
bitcoin and then two which cars you were
gonna get
well so what happened was my i need like
i i had a mercedes and i crashed kind of
crashed in the garage just
ripped the bumper off um
and so i don't i was going to get a new
one and then i was just like
uh i didn't like the new model of the
mercedes so i got a range laser
uh my dad had always wanted a jag he
never had one as a kid because he never
you know he pursued private schools he
never had any money
so he was due to renew his car and i was
like well do you what do you want to jag
and he said
yeah so so i bought him that
and then um and then i was kind of a bit
bored of the rangers so i thought i'd
get uh me and my son went out during the
lockdown
um
and there was like uh next atlantic
eating garages and that's engaged we
were looking at the cars i was like john
that one's pretty neat so so i bought
that and then my son uh needed there's
no real rash i don't know i'm just
explaining there's enough there's no
thought process my son needed a car and
over the last two years three years i've
done the podcast he's been super helpful
but because all my interviews are in the
evenings
uh because you americans are a few hours
behind there's so many times where he's
been like making dinner for him and his
sister or he's just have to sit around
and work him so i was like you know i'll
buy you a nice car so there's no real
like set plans some was bought cash some
i sold a little bit of bitcoin but i
rebought that bitcoin there's no real
plan i can't give you like a solid arms
i just bought four cars in the space of
two months
hey
what people forget is you gotta live
your life you got to enjoy it as well
right you're sitting in torches
uh drinking a pina colada right now like
screw us we got to get your life
okay this podcast getting kind of worked
out isn't it
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it